big news tonight on uranium one we're
learning that the FBI informant at the
center of the scandal in fact told
congressional committees that Russia
paid millions to the u.s. lobbying firm
APCO Worldwide in a bid to influence
then Secretary of State Hillary Clinton
by helping Bill Clinton's charities and
a statement obtained by Fox News the
informant says that Russian nuclear
officials told him at various times
quote they expected aapko to apply a
portion of the three million dollar
annual lobbying fee it was receiving
from the Russians to provide in-kind
support for the Clintons Global
Initiative and APCO was expected to give
assistance free of charge to the Clinton
Global Initiative as part of their
effort to create a favorable environment
to ensure the Obama administration made
affirmative decisions on everything from
uranium 1 to the u.s. Russian civilian
nuclear cooperation agreement we did
reach out to aapko for comment they told
us in part the allegations are false and
I'm founded aapko also told us that it's
volunteer work for the Clinton Global
Initiative and its engagement with the
Russian firm Tenex are absolutely not
connected and last night a Clinton
spokesman called the FBI inform in a
charade joining us now with reaction
Republican congressman Matt Gaetz Fox
News contributor Sarah Carter we welcome
back John Solomon from the hill John
let's start with you a lot was said
about Hillary and all this give you a
chance to lay this out yeah I think the
most interesting thing is we now have a
really complete timeline of what the FBI
knew when and we now know that before
the Obama administration made the
following decisions restarted the US
nuclear cooperation agreement with
Russia approved the uranium 1 deal and
then gave clearance so that many
utilities in the United States could buy
Russian uranium they knew the following
things at least through the FBI they
knew this one that Russia was assisting
Iran and their illicit nuclear program -
that the aapko the lobbying firm at
least the Russians were claiming they
were paying money to them in an effort
to bid to help Hillary Clinton in 3 the
very Russian armed Raza Tom's arm in the
United States that was sent here to
build this uranium business was engaged
in bribery kickbacks racketeering and
extortion
if
you have all that information it does
raise a great public policy question why
did the Obama administration the Hillary
Clinton State Department the other
departments why did they approve these
deals unbelievable there was never any
sense to that sir I see you shaking your
head
both you and John a bit at the forefront
of all this you both know the informant
yes and these are thousands of documents
Shawn saved from the time he was working
with the FBI as an undercover informant
and I stress again he's spent nearly
three decades working with US
intelligence agencies that includes the
FBI on many and many issues a number of
issues and I want to go back to one
point in April 2010 is when he informed
the FBI of what he found out regarding
Russia and Iran they were aiding Iran
with their fabricated assemblies for
their nuclear reactors with consultation
and with fuel so the Obama
administration actually knew that this
was going on there was documented proof
there were recordings but yet in October
2010 they still went through with the
deal thus if he has approved the deal
for the sale of the Canadian form
uranium one which had 20% of our uranium
mining assets in the United States in
Wyoming in particular so we have to ask
ourselves these questions and say if
there is an investigation it's going to
be up to those investigators at the
Department of Justice and others yet to
look at the money trail unbelievable I
know and we're gonna learn a lot more
about that both you and John aggrieved I
see both shaking your head
congressman gates in it we don't have
enough uranium congressman the idea that
that FBI director at the time Muller
knew because we had the informant about
bribery extortion kickbacks money
laundering and this is eight what nearly
eighteen months before Sofia signs off
on the uranium one deal
knowing Vladimir Putin wanted a foot
hole foot holding in our industry it's
mind-numbing that this could have ever
happened well and it seems to indicate
Sean that you would have to have some
type of improper influence to end up
with these facts the real question is
whether or not there's going to be any
consequences because the Clintons for
decades are used to having a different
standard of Justice applied to them than
is applied to the rest of the
American people that's why I filed
legislation with countless other
conservative colleagues like Mark
meadows and Jim Jordan and Todd Rokita
calling for a second special council to
look into the Clinton Foundation in
uranium one because I mean we can't have
Muller investigate he should have raised
an objection we can't have a Rosenstein
investigate because we've already seen
the extent to which he's tied up and a
lot of these facts and Jeff Sessions has
recused himself so the only way this
doesn't become the next Benghazi where
we stir up a bunch of facts but then let
the Clintons off the hook is to appoint
a special counsel and we need arms on
generally what's separate and apart from
the special counsel investigating the
investigators we have so much to get to
so little time John and Sarah in
particular want I want to ask you will
we hear from the informant you both know
John that's a good question I mean this
interview was a non transcribed
interview with staff not members of
Congress and I would expect that both
staffs will meet decide what he told
them and decide whether they want to
have a public hearing I think that's the
next step will we hear from him yes I
believe we will and I think it's vitally
important for him to speak publicly I
know that he wants to but he wants to
follow the proper process and that's
with his attorney Victoria Thanh Singh
and she will I think make it affordable
for the American people to see him
unbelievable work it will continue to
peel away the layers of the onion here
you guys have done a phenomenal work
over the last year we thank you